vous avez un appel en pcv en provenance
d'un détenu de la prison de x moreau
ok alors tu veux qu'on vienne le
chercher non c'est bon j'ai mon camion
et réanimer
[Musique]
on s'est pas vu depuis super longtemps
j'ai de l'alcool j'ai de la bouffe
gilles lapierre ans qui sous soir aux
mines amont
s'est retrouvé dans les bois précieux
prochain le rocher est une nouvelle
telle est la mienne est plus grand même
et discuter un succès sans déconner elle
est pas belle la mission d'ici père
des bières pas par un jour j'espère y
aura plus à travailler situe elle doit
se trouver un diplôme dans le marketing
ou la technologie à l'université puisque
tu connais la prodigieuse ça les réseaux
sociaux m'habiter sur les réseaux
sociaux
on est tous ensemble
ouais au salut c'est froch
tu vas prendre à 93 vers le nord prendra
un certain temps et là tu verras à mon
garage c'est seul bar accueillait des
lumières en ce moment est quelqu'un qui
doit venir ouais un gamin il veut venir
ici
[Musique]
je te présente mais pas tous je vous
présente shadow walker
et vous voulez bien vous occuper notre
invité souplet j'ai une histoire douce
regarde ça
de quoi tu parlais tout à l'heure
ça va être marrant tu arrives quoi je
travaille dans ce cas rage depuis plus
de dix ans pour offrir un avenir à ma
fille
qu'est ce qui se passe [ __ ]
il a détruit la vie de ma fille on va te
tuer
mon père va vous attaquez les trois
ratés
quand au sortir de ce merdier
je voulais que ce soit un peu spécial
quoi
[Musique]